und damit willkommen zurück zu bild live
bei uns im studio jetzt säge braun
kanzleramtsminister schön dass die zeit
für uns haben sie haben ja gestern ich
habe schon gesagt ein bisschen was
ausgelöst ein interview der bild am
sonntag wir können uns mal das zitat
angucken in der grafik sie haben nämlich
gesagt geimpfte werden mehr freiheiten
haben als ungeimpfte und zwar selbst
wenn diese ungenutzten kerngesund und
negativ getestet sind wir sind sind auf
diese idee gekommen das ist keine idee
sondern wir haben ja in der pandemie die
ganze zeit schon eine situation über die
wir diskutieren
kommt es wieder zu einem hohen
infektionsgeschehen und wenn wir wieder
in eine situation mit rom
infektionsgeschehen kommen dann ist
immer die ultima ratio die das letzte
mittel kontakte beschränken um die
infektion zu bremsen und das wollen wir
genau vermeiden und deshalb arbeiten wir
jetzt daran dass wir eine hohe impfquote
haben dann kommt das alles nicht zum
tragen wenn wir es schaffen so eine art
gemeinschafts immunität oder
herdenimmunität zu bilden und ansonsten
kann man natürlich auch getesteten sehr
viel ermöglichen ähnlich wie geimpften
und genesen
aber wenn das nicht ausreicht da muss
man wissen
dann kann es als letzte ultima ratio
notwendig sei neben dass auch diejenigen
die sich nicht durch impfen weitgehend
aus der pandemie rausgenommen hat das
auch da wieder kontakt beschränkungen
notwendig wären hätten sie haben gerade
gesagt sie gucken die ganze zeit auf die
frage steigen die instanzen aber die
weit ist doch sie als regierung sollten
noch vor allem auf eine frage schauen
droht wieder eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser mit aus ihrer sicht beim
derzeitigen im stand oder dem absehbaren
im stand droht noch eine überlastung der
intensivstation für den herbst ja und
das brot hat man kann aus ihrer sicht
droht noch im herbst eine überlastung
der intensivstation man kann es
jedenfalls nicht ausschließen aus zwei
gründen
das eine ist das momentan sich die del
tabelle sagt man diese vierte welle
relativ schnell entwickelt also mit
hohen steigerungsraten jede woche in
anderen ländern aber nach wenigen tagen
england niederlande selbst indien wieder
abgeflacht ist aber an vielen stellen
nicht ohne maßnahmen also die die ich
ich damit aufhebung aller maßnahmen
wieder abgeflacht aber
in england steigen die zahlen weiter in
england segen zahlen gefallen ein in
großbritannien sind die zahlen gefallen
in england steigen sie und in schottland
fallen sie und da sind die schulen zu
noch einmal
sie glauben dass es eine überlasst dass
eine überlastung der krankenhäuser trotz
impfung mit dem derzeitigen fortschritt
möglich ist dazu würde ich ihnen gerne
mal vorlesen was sie im märz gesagt
haben wenn wir jedem in deutschland ein
impf angebot gemacht haben dann können
wir zur normalität in allen bereichen
zurückkehren diejenigen die ihr angebot
nicht wahrnehmen treffen ihre
individuelle entscheidung dass sie das
erkrankungsrisiko akzeptieren
danach können wir aber keine grundrechts
einschränkung eines anderen mehr
rechtfertigen dann kehren wir im vollen
umfang zur normalität zurück und alle
einschränkungen fallen ende september
glaube ich habe alle in angebot ungefähr
ende september anfang oktober
aber das geht dann nicht mehr oder wie
sollen wir es verstehen aufgrund der
delta variante mit dem was jetzt zu tun
da muss man einfach sagen ich stehe zu
dieser aussage zu 100 prozent dies
richtig aber sie hat momentan zwei
probleme das eine ist wir können nicht
der gesamten bevölkerung ein impfangebot
machen weil wir eben für kinder noch gar
keinen impfstoff haben das heißt wir
müssen immer auch fragen gibt es noch
eine rücksichtslos wendigkeit auf
diejenigen die keine impfmöglichkeit
haben erfahren dass - das wussten sie
doch vor wochen dass sie für kinder in
dem sinne kein impfstoff haben als schon
die rede davon war war vollkommen klar
dass das exklusive kinder ist das kann
man auch jetzt nicht im nachhinein
anpassen nein und das zweite argument
und das ist auch sehr wichtig ist dass
wir eine dass das quasi der fall ist bin
ich dort beschrieben habe für diese
gemeinschaft immunität das heißt die
zahl derer die sich impfen lassen um so
hoch sein dass sie quasi den den den
gesellschaftlichen schutz für die
ungeimpften ein stück mit organisieren
die gruppe derer die sich nicht impfen
lassen möchten so groß sein sollte und
nur für den fall also der reden über die
frage müssen wir ungeimpfte anders
behandeln nur über den fall wenn die
gruppe so groß ist in deutschland
es ist eine welle wandte pandemische
welle gibt weil es zu viele sind die
sich nicht am impfen lässt dann machen
wir mal eine zahl dran wie viel prozent
brauchen wir damit die bundesregierung
sich nicht weiter das recht herausnimmt
menschen zu sagen ob sie ins restaurant
gehen dürfen oder nicht
was ist für sie her 89 75 70 welche
zahlen schwebt ihnen vor ihm stehen sie
diesmal zu der zahl oder gibt es dann
wieder pressekonferenzen wo plötzlich
andere zahlen kommen nein das wir haben
ja zu keinem zeitpunkt irgendwie gesagt
daher gibt es eine zahl der ist alles
gut sondern wir haben immer wieder
verschiedene indikatoren genannten wenn
man erst gesagt wenn jeder ein angebot
hatte ist alles gut und jetzt sagen sie
wenn eine zahl erreicht ist deswegen
würden wir gerne wie lautet die zeit
weil offenbar hat sich der was geändert
es ist nicht mehr das angebot denn es
muss eine zahl erreicht zeit wie lautet
die zeit
nein ich habe nicht genug muss eine zahl
erreicht sein das muss eine
gemeinschafts immunität aber richtig
darunter kann sich hier keiner unserer
zuschauer was vorstellen ja also die
liegt oberhalb von 80 prozent das hat
das lka auch besagte richtung 85 prozent
kommt man in die region aber am ende
entscheidend ist nicht eine zahl sondern
am ende ist entscheidend dass wir in der
gesellschaft einfach sehen wir verhalten
uns wieder normal aber das virus hat
trotzdem keine chance mehr sich massiv
zu verbreiten das ist das eigentliche
kriterien und darum geht's dahin
warum haben sie das nicht von anfang an
gesagt sondern erst gesagt wenn alle ein
angebot hatten also 85 prozent müssen
uns annehmen hätte man ja auch schon vor
monaten sagen können haben sie auch
nicht getan ich habe es immer genau so
gesagt wir werden mit einem zunehmendem
fortschritt verliert die pandemie in
deutschland in schrecken angebot habe
nicht fortschritt angebot hat nein das
dass das wenn wir ja gesagt jedem einen
van steen hat der satz steht in einem
kontext und der kontext war immer das
ziel so oder so sein dass wir völlig zur
normalität übergeben müssen ist dann
wenn wir quasi diese gemeinschaft
immunität erreicht haben und dann aber
das haben sie muss sich sozusagen den
schutz
dann muss ich den schutz des ungeliebten
nicht mehr zum anlass nehmen für
grundrechts einschränkungen weil er sich
entschieden hat selber dass er lieber
das erkrankungs als das impfwesen also
78 hatte das
sozusagen dieses individuelle recht
recht noch nicht das individuelle recht
sich nicht impfen zu lassen tritt erst
ab einer gewissen individuell rächt sich
nicht impfen zu lassen
deshalb finde ich auch nur ganz klar
sagen die vermischung mit einer
impfpflicht oder einer impfpflicht durch
den tür das kann man nun wirklich bei
dabei nicht sagen sondern es gibt
einfach den unterschied dass diejenigen
wir haben wird wir leben seit anderthalb
jahren in einer pandemie in dieser
pandemie haben wir mehrfach festgestellt
dass einschränkung unserer freiheiten
notwendig waren um die pandemie zu
beherrschen muss man viel geld mal sagen
die bundesregierung ist der meinung dass
das notwendig war
andere länder haben das nicht getan sind
zu identischen ergebnissen in allen
kurven zu raps identischen ergebnis
kommt ansicht der bundesregierung das
notwendig war nicht ein objektiver
fakten nur einmal zehn ordnung nur
einmal zur einfachen würde ich aber
sagen erstens dass der weit überwiegende
teil der deutschen bevölkerung diese das
unterstützt absolutes weitere erste teil
der bevölkerung auch auf 30 jedenfalls
kein land kenne das ohne beschränkende
maßnahmen aus gekommen wäre und dadurch
sinkende zahlen erreicht herbei ich bin
einmal ganz kurz auf diese 80 85 prozent
wenn wir uns jetzt einmal ehrlich machen
wie realistisch ist denn diese zahl ist
doch völlig unrealistisch das glaube ich
gar nicht sondern wenn man wenn man sich
die umfragen anguckt liegt die
impfbereitschaft in deutschland ziemlich
genau so in der größenordnung ist so
echte menschen die bewusst sagen ich
möchte mich nicht impfen lassen liegt
nach umfragen jedenfalls in der
größenordnung von 15 prozent und das was
wir den leuten jetzt sagen müssen jetzt
ist der zeitpunkt sich wirklich um das
impfangebot zu kümmern
impfen jetzt weil bis man seinen
vollständigen impfschutz hat das dauert
ja nun mal sechs bis acht wochen
und deshalb wehre sich vor dieser
del-tabelle schützen will jetzt beginnt
die stärker und schneller steigt als die
wellen die wir bisher gesehen haben
auch wenn sie noch niedrig ist aber als
verantwortliche regierungspolitiker muss
ich den leuten nicht sagen wir müssen
uns jetzt kümmern wenn das ding brunnen
ist und dann wenn es losgeht und jetzt
geht es los
und deshalb sollten die leute jetzt
zügig ein impf angebot wahrnehmen nicht
mehr warten weil wir haben
impfstoff und wir müssen schneller
impfen als der täter werde sich aus sie
verbieten im moment als staat entweder
als bundesregierung oder als lernendes
regierung im moment sind es vor allem
die länder ganz viele dinge wenn wir uns
schlecht viele in der kirche singen
wollen ist es immer noch vielerorts
verboten
mit welcher was ist ihr grund dafür dass
sie sagen wir dürfen euch solche dinge
verbieten dinge die teilweise
grundrechte sind was ist was ihre
argumentation wenden sie immer noch ein
kollaps unseres gesundheitssystems ab
oder was ist ihr grund dafür in
grundrechte eingreifen zu dürfen
natürlich am ende ist es so dass wenn
wir keine maßnahmen ergreifen würden
würde natürlich das impf geschehen jetzt
noch schneller schneller steigen und
deshalb ist es zum beispiel zwingend
erfordern oder das infektionsgeschehen
das infektionsherden noch schneller
schneller steigen wenn es keine
maßnahmen mehr hätten und deshalb muss
man sich einfach mal vorstellen wenn
eine ganz wichtige maßnahme um das in
das infektionsgeschehen zu bremsen ist
ja zum beispiel die quarantäne und bei
jeder großveranstaltung wo es jetzt zum
infektionsgeschehen kommt wo man dann
damit sagen muss da gibt es nicht zehn
kontaktpersonen sollen 400 werden auf
kosten der allgemeinheit 400 menschen in
quarantäne geschickt wissen eigentlich
doppelt geimpfte noch in quarantäne weil
das weiß auch keiner mehr so genau in
diesem land doppelt geimpften
grundsätzlich nicht in quarantäne
aber mit der bundesländer schon kann man
das nicht wenn es dazu wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse gibt man einheitlich regeln
also das hängt ja auch an den länder-
verordnungen das ist richtig aber wir
wissen auch bei der delta variante dass
der impfschutz gut wirkt und dass er
auch einen guten schutz vor der
weiterverbreitung der infektion und das
ist eine quarantäne
wenn man kontaktperson ist als geimpfter
nicht erfordert eine 900 tschuldigung
kirche von den 900 g n aachen in diesem
apollo club irgendwie möglicherweise in
der reichweite eines infizierten waren
sind alle in quarantäne ihre botschaft
an die doppel kämpften von denen die
dürfen wieder raus oder das wenn das
gesundheitsamt vor ort dafür nur
besondere begründung hat dann muss das
vor ort entschieden werden aber
grundsätzlich ist es so
das auch das rkw und sehr gesagt hat
dass von den geimpften und den genesenen
und ge vielleicht nach geimpften das
epidemische geschehen kein wesentlicher
beitrag mehr aus dieser zeit gilt es ja
dass ungeimpfte bzw
geimpfte menschen und negativ getestet
die gleichen rechte haben bzw eben
gleich viele sachen machen dürfen warum
werden denn diese tests also sei es kann
ja dahinter hinkommen dass man dass es
nicht mehr ausreicht sich negativ testen
zu lassen
sind diese tests so schlecht oder warum
könnte das zu problemen kommen ja also
das sind der getestete hat sozusagen
gegenüber dem geimpften zwei nachteile
und der erste ist der ganz große er kann
sich weiter anstecken davor schützt in
der test natürlich überhaupt nicht und
damit ist er noch in der in der pandemie
im epidemischen geschehen drin und das
zweite ist dass der der test keine
hundertprozentige sicherheit gibt
sondern bei solchen rein testungen in
der größenordnung von 60 prozent dh auch
die gefahr dass einer der doch infiziert
ist beim testen mal durchrutscht ist
gerade wenn das infektionsgeschehen sehr
hoch ist
doch sehr relevant jetzt bei so einem
niedrigen infektionsgeschehen nicht
deshalb sagen wir auch der erste schritt
ist die impfen genesenen und getesteten
vieles ermöglichen aber bei den
ungeimpften dann auf den test sozusagen
den test zu verlangen
und das was wir sozusagen nur so viel
aufregung ausgelöst hat ist der hinweis
wenn das infektionsgeschehen aber sehr
sehr hoch wird und damit diese 40
prozent die beim test sozusagen nicht
erkannt werden einfach zu einer
relevanten größe
dann muss man auch darüber eben nach da
möchte ich ganz kurz einmal rein denn
nicht geimpft ist ja auch ein synonym
für kinder unter 12 das bedeutet ja in
ihrer theorie dass ab herbst wenn die
zahlen steigen alle eltern in diesem
land mit kindern und dann zwölf ihren
kinder wieder sein können
wir können nicht zur bundesliga wir
können nicht ins kino wir können nicht
ins theater weil sie nicht games sind
also zunächst mal geht es ja darum wenn
sich alle eltern und auswendig ganz
wichtig das beste was wir für unsere
kinder tun können
ist das die erwachsenen sich jetzt
impfen lassen wenn wir das breit
erreichen dann ist das ganze thema
makulatur
die kinder selbst bin ich auch dafür
dass wir verstärkt jetzt diese leute
testung diese diese cluster testung
machen also in der schule gar nicht mit
nasenabstrich sondern mit in diesem lutz
verfahren wo wir eine sehr sehr hohe
quote bekommen aber wenn man einfach an
diesen herbst denkt im herbst ist das
problem wenn das infektionsgeschehen so
hoch wird nur über den fall reden wäre
dann ist doch das problem der kinder und
jugendlichen nicht die freizeit sondern
das problem ist dann die schule weil wir
bei einem hohen infektionsgeschehen und
lauter kind an die nicht geimpft sind
dann findet doch dort auch ein
relevantes infektionsgeschehen statt das
den schulbetrieb auch irgendwie
schwierig macht und deshalb ist es auch
aus der sicht für einen guten
schulbetrieb doch sinnvoll nicht ein
beliebiges infektions es komplett anders
die eltern großeltern und was mit den
kindern ist es wunderbar der die am
leichte verläufe versagens uns alle
mediziner seit einem jahr
ja die kinder haben leichte verläufe
aber heißt das denn im umkehrschluss
dass wir in diesem herbst nachdem wir
nachdem wir die pandemie jetzt soweit
bewältigt haben
in kauf nehmen dass ein großteil unserer
gesamten jugend jetzt die krankheit
durch macht ich finde das ist ein
schwieriger moment
österreichs bundeskanzler sebastian kurz
hat bei uns gestern abend in die
richtigen fragen gesagt natürlich machen
die schulen auf bleiben auf wird
normalen schulbetrieb geben können wenn
eine ähnliche zusage aus dem kanzleramt
für deutschland nach den sommerferien
das kanzleramt für die schulen gar nicht
sprechen aber natürlich ist es dass das
a und o dass wir für die zweite
jahreshälfte sicheren schulbetrieb haben
wollen und dem empfinde ich das ist es
was wir wollen ist ja vollkommen klar
aber wir haben leider trotz unserer
großartigen recherche kapazitäten leider
in deutschland noch niemanden gefunden
auf länderebene nicht aufkommen eben
nicht im kanzleramt nicht der gesagt hat
ja ab den sommerferien gehen die kinder
wieder so zur schule wie früher
naja weil das ich persönlich glaube dass
oft wird gerade viel getan wird um den
schulbetrieb zu verbessern
aber am ende haben wir auch im letzten
winter war ja auch dass da viel getan
wird ja das ist ja schon aber der eine
punkt haben wir auch gelernt wir hatten
ja einen großen streit im winter im
letzten winter nach dem motto können wir
quasi ein großes infektionsgeschehen in
deutschland tolerieren und schützen die
gruppen die wir besonders sieht
besonders schützen müssen
dadurch dass wir separieren oder um die
maßnahmen machen damals ging es
hauptsächlich um die älteren den alten
ein ja ergebnis nicht geschützt worden
und wir haben gemerkt dass das bis zu
einem gewissen punkt an
infektionsgeschehen uns gelungen ist und
ab einem gewissen punkt überhaupt nicht
mehr sondern dann kam ein weihnachtsmann
drei tagen könnte es hat auch nichts
damit zu tun wie das infektionsgeschehen
war doch sein nein es hat etwas damit zu
tun dass vor den heimen wo 40 prozent
der toten zu verzeichnen sind von keiner
landesregierung und auch viel zu spät
von der bundesregierung mit schleusen so
geschützt worden ist es ist über monate
nicht vorher getestet worden das hat ja
nichts mit der insolvenz zu tun sondern
einfach mit versagen beim testen
also wir hatten wir haben ab oktober
alle schnelltests komplett für die
pflegeheime und für das gesundheitswesen
reserviert genau deshalb haben wir in
der breiten bevölkerung nicht anfangen
können mit schnelltests arbeiten weil
wir gesagt dann da werden sie am
dringendsten gebraucht also haben viel
gemacht und über weihnachten waren war
es die bundesregierung die die
bundeswehr in die pflege einmal sechs
monate da seit sechs monaten ist ein
sechs monate gedauert um die leute von
denen wir wussten dass sie geschützt
werden müssen zu schützen
nein wir haben vorher haben wir die
pflegeheime ausgestattet und das sind ja
auch und unprofessionell einrichtungen
die sehr viel selbst getan haben und wir
haben gesehen und auch bis dahin im
oktober als dass die infektionszahlen
bevor diese november welle kam hatten
wir auch das infektionsgeschehen in den
pflegeeinrichtungen war sehr sehr
niedrig die zahl der ausbrüche wer war
sehr gering
und man sieht einfach dass wenn das
infektionsgeschehen ein gewisses ausmaß
erreicht das ist einfach auch leider
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung dann wird es
immer schwerer solche wohl mehr atmen
einrichtungen zu schützen und das kann
man jetzt übertragen
aus meiner sicht auf die frage wie gehen
wir mit den schulen und ich bin
überzeugt bei einem niedrigen
infektionsgeschehen kann man mit
maßnahmen auch den schulbetrieb
sicherstellen wenn man eine gewisse höhe
des infektionsgeschehen sin kaufen was
irgendwann zu hoch wird dann wird es
auch da schwierig er brauche ich glaube
sie müssen zurück ins kanzleramt vielen
dank das sicher heute morgen gestellt
haben und alles gute wer gern wo ich
hier geht's lang